the veteran asher wojciechowski making
his fourth start of the year he's owen
two with a good three point nine
five era 13 in each pitch 15 punch-outs
which is really good five walks so three
to one upon sitting 224 off of him
dribble cabrera at the plate leads the
gnats with 13 rbis
so it'll be running down at first
full count pitch on the way and he got
him on strikes
he
gives up a base hit and a walk but no
damage there is patrick corbin the
left-hander three starts this year three
quality starts so he's worked at least
six innings three earned runs or less
and all three of his starts you see the
era it's outstanding and look at the
strikeouts for walks 20 punch-outs only
three walks opponents hitting just 217
off the left-hander patrick corbin and
sarah alberto the 3-2 to alberto
swing and
a foul tip into the glove of gomes
strike three on a sinker down and away
so alberto strikes out to begin the
bottom of the first orioles making some
noise here second and third and only one
out comes the one-two pitch
hit hard lying to the shortstop and
everybody back with base running nobody
got doubled off nunez hit it hard so two
down may take a hit to get him in now
and here's pedro severino 308 on the
batting average four homers three two
semolino fair ball
into the left field corner that'll score
two the orioles on top two nothing with
a two run double from pedro severino how
about you pedro severino so one on one
out and andrew velasquez is the batter
first pitch swinging
that's a fair ball into the right field
corner for velazquez
holiday into third got the green light
he's coming to the plate here comes the
throw
and he slides and he's safe and the
orioles go up three nothing another run
out there
they should get him home fly ball to
ride eaton
velazquez tags here he comes there'll be
no play and the oreos get another run
here's juan soto batting third for the
first time and he gets to bat with a
runner at first nobody out
[Applause]
well did he get it it's heading to left
center i think he did
see
you
later a tasty homer for juan soto and
that's his
sixth rbi total up to 14.
breaking ball garcia the center field
velasquez coming on makes the catch to
end the inning rules have ruiz starting
off this inning against patrick corbin
the one-to-one offering ruiz swings
drives this one deep right field into
the corner this fall is it gone it is
it's over the wall as it just barely
clears the 21 foot high wall in right
field mario ruiz it's home run number
six on the season
fastball away and they get the grounder
turner
four six three a beauty for the nets
last of the fifth inning patrick corbin
back to work breaking ball check swing
he went after the ball all the way to
the backstop gomes will pick it up
saborino running to first but first base
occupied he's automatically out payoff
pitch for the right-handed hitting
valencia on the way swinging a line
drive right field eating in his tracks
weights and makes the catch and that'll
do it for the orioles in the fifth hit a
wild pitcher man left to second through
five sixth inning trey turner leading
off and a swing a long drive to left for
turf forget about this one it is going
going and long gone about 15 rows into
the seats and straight away left now
wojciechowski's first pitch in the sixth
inning is crushed by trey turner for his
fourth home run of the season there is
tanner scott the hard-throwing
left-hander see he's worked in seven
games now and he has been good
two-two bounced to second
alberto over the first one down one-two
bounced to second alberto
wide throw but it gets there in time
nice job by nunez
oh great pitch there and how about
tanner scott get some one two three the
two three and four hitters kyle finnegan
the big right-hander who has been
outstanding this year for the nationals
five games pitch doesn't have a record
but doesn't have an era either a lot of
zeroes there so now the orioles have the
runner 90 feet away trying to add to
their lead blind drive
ball it's into the corner
velazquez scored alberto hustling to
second here comes the throw and he's in
with a double another rbi for hancer
alberto and the orioles tack on and now
lead at 6-3
sounded like a busted bat and garcia
back to make an outstanding play and a
sliding grab saves an rbi hit there
wander suero is in four games 6.75 era
he's worked in five innings giving up
eight hits punched out four walked one
suero kicks delivers first pitch cutter
pulling the ground to first in between
hop backhanded by his drupal cabrera who
steps on first for the out
and there's a curve breaking ball
swung out of mist it's in the dirt
golems throws down to cabrera to
complete the strikeout two to three now
jose iglesias the batters double to left
grounded a third single left there he
goes running again and this time
delivered into right field that'll score
a run
santander around a third and give
iglesias an rbi and his third hit of the
game eric thames and that's last chance
the good one this should do it
cedric mullins in
and the orioles have defeated the gnats